bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france 24
le lundi 14 mars lors du journal
télévisé sur la chaîne pervyi kanal la
principale chaîne d'état russe une femme
fait irruption et montre un panneau
s'opposant à la guerre en ukraine cette
femme c'est marina hawks et nico va et
c'est notre invité aujourd'hui depuis
moscou merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
beaucoup de votre invitation tout
d'abord je tiens à remercier le
président macron de sa proposition
incroyable
il m'a proposé de déménager en france
il m'a proposé d'accorder l'asile
politique mais malheureusement je ne
pourrai pas saisir cette
proposition parce que je suis patriote
je veux rester et vivre dans mon pays
avec ma famille j'ai tous mes amis ici
et je veux rester en russie alors vous
avez été
condamné à une amende de 30000 roubles
environ 250 euros reconnu coupable
d'avoir commis ce qu'on appelle une
infraction administrative
pas tellement pour ce que vous avez fait
lors de cette intrusion mais aussi part
à cause d'une vidéo que vous avez posté
sur les réseaux sociaux où vous dénoncez
la guerre en ukraine comme un crime la
russie comme l'agresseur est vladimir
poutine comme le responsable et vous
appelé les russes à manifester
aujourd'hui donc vous avez été libéré
mais est ce que vous craignez d'autres
poursuites notamment des poursuites
pénales
vous savez
[Musique]
en effet j'ai reçu
la
demande pour moi
punition administratives pour vie cette
vidéo que j'ai fait circuler j'ai dans
laquelle j'explique mon geste
s'était qualifié
comme un appel un appel à descendre dans
la rue et de
manifester
effectivement on ne sait l'histoire ne
se termine
cette
amende
parce que je ne parle et est encore
sanctionné pour cette interruption
pendant le journal télévisé donc je
pense que donc je vais objets
des
sanctions
autre sanction ces sanctions peuvent
être graves marina on sait que
la diffusion la publication de ce que
les autorités russes appellent les
informations mensongères entre
guillemets est un crime aujourd'hui
passible d'une peine maximale de 15 ans
de prison c'est ce que vous craignez
je le dis parce que cette poursuite
pénale est tout à fait réelle je risque
d'or
d'obtenir 15 ans d'emprisonnement et
j'espère bien éviter cela
pourquoi alors avoir fait ce geste vous
connaissiez les conséquences vous ne
vous attendiez peut-être parce que ça
ait un tel écho au tour de la planète
mais pourquoi ce geste vous y avez
réfléchi ce n'est pas un geste spontané
c'est un geste difficile parce que vous
travaillez dans un média qui évidemment
est à l'opposé de ce que vous avez
exprimées
vous savez je pense que j'ai
surtout ce mécontentement qui sait qu il
est avec des années mais le
mécontentement cause de la propagande
tout au début les élections des
gouverneurs ont été annulés puis à 2014
leyrit public ait les nerfs des nerfs
ensuite la
l'empoisonnement de navalni son
emprisonnement et la dernière goutte
le point de non retour
fut cette invasion des soldats russes à
l'ukraine
russe
ordinaire
trouver une explication comment on
pouvait envoyer nos forces armées dans
un autre pays table qui compte 2 il mais
j'ai émis aucune de mes connaissances
nous croyez en ce scénario il ne pense
non ne pensais même
que c'était possible
je pense
qu'il faut mettre un terme à tout cela
le plus rapidement possible mais vous
avez fait partie de cette chaîne qui
diffuse les informations que le kremlin
veut voir
diffuser
ce qu'il ya eu vraiment un élément
déclencheur parce que on on pourrait
dire mais vous avez accepté tout cela
pourquoi tout d'un coup ne plus pouvoir
l'accepter
nous
eh bien c'est ce que je dis c'est la
guerre à nu cren mais cette guerre qui
est devenu le point de non retour
et le le facteur déclencheur
les gens ne pensais même pas que cela
allait se produire que c'était hier aux
horribles le 24 février j'ai perdu
sommet j'ai perdu
absolument tous les repères dans ma vie
je t'en veux pas manger
j'ai compris que je pouvais pas garder
le silence
j'ai appris cette nouvelle loi
qui
permettait de poursuivre tous les gens
qui descendait dans la rue
j'ai tout de suite décédée décidé de me
joindre
ces actions de protestation j'ai suivi
les événements dans
les glaces à moscou j'ai tout de suite
compris ico
ses actions pouvaient pas être efficace
tellement elle était un bris d ainsi
j'ai pris la décision de faire ce geste
et
de
d'envoyer un message fort
pour dire que les rues sont contre la
guerre
pour dire que une compte il ne faut pas
se fier à la propagande et côté ce qu'on
dit de la télévision de la télévision et
qu'il faut
faire cette distinction entre le
mensonge et la vérité alors vladimir
poutine a dénoncé ce mercredi je le cite
les traîtres aux nationaux il a parlé
d'une auto purification nécessaire de la
société russe il a dit je le cite tout
peuple en particulier le peuple russe
est capable de distinguer les vrais
patriotes des racailles et des traîtres
et de les recracher comme un moucheron
qui serait accidentellement entré dans
leur bouche ça vous fait peur quand vous
entendez vladimir poutine dire ça après
ce que vous avez fait
j'ai peur bien sûr mais je ne pense pas
que je fais partie de la racaille
russa qui ont leur position citoyenne et
ne se taisent
ne sont pas signalés par haquin
effectivement les gens qui descendent
dans la rue pour protester ce sont pas
des traîtres de leur pays ce sont des
citoyen avec leurs positions de citoyen
est ce que vous avez reçu des menaces ou
des intimidations depuis votre intrusion
sur le studio de la première chaîne
publiquement personne m'a menacée mais
il y a certains commentaires peut-être
qu'ils sont publiés sur internet je n'ai
pas le temps de les lire et maintenant
j'essaie de limiter
effectivement il de me préserver mais je
pense qu'il y aura des commentaires
forcément d'argent vous savez si tu as
que la société russe
et dit viser
une partie où peut-être la moitié est
pas contre la guerre et l'amour est
là le président poutine et souhaite
continuer cette opération est ce que
vous avez quitté votre chaîne de
télévision
oui
aujourd'hui je me suis rendu à un stade
qui est non j'ai transmis tous les
documents pour mon licenciés mans sur ma
décision mais c'est une procédure
juridique
d'autres
tête bien connue à la télévision russe
ont pris leurs distances ou pris des
vacances on pense notamment à yann à
hague à la cova l'une des aussi l'une
des stars de votre chaîne ivan origone
tu es ce que pour vous c'est un signal
c'est une façon peut-être moins visible
que vous de manifester ou est ce que
c'est la peur
bien sûr que les gens ont peur
peu de gens
de faire un tel geste surtout
ces derniers temps mais nous voyons une
tendance positive est également ces
derniers temps sur des chaînes de
télévision
je sais
qu'il ya un certain nombre d'autres des
collègues qui ont
écrit des lettres qui ont déposé lors
ces licenciements demande de
licenciement ça nous réjouit mais bon
vous connaissez très bien que maintenant
la situation économique est très
compliquée a réussi donc peu de gens
peuvent se permettre tout simplement de
se retrouver sur le carreau
travail parce qu'ils ont des mensualités
impayées
à payer leur maison
aux médias étrangers sont fermés et donc
les journalistes professionnels ne
peuvent travailler maintenant que sur
des chaînes d'état juste très rapidement
pour finir vous avez deux enfants est ce
qu'ils sont fiers de leur maman
aujourd'hui
très compliqué de
dire ainsi tout d'abord ils sont très
apeuré ils ont peur surtout monfils a
les noms déjà il pense moi que j'ai
brisé la vie de notre famille par ce
geste mais moi je lui explique qu'il
faut dans lève
réagir et prendre des décisions
compliquées surtout pour mettre un terme
à cette guerre fratricide
pour surtout ne pas amener
faut lire
et la transformer en guerre nucléaire
et donc quand mon fils sera un peu d'une
langue
je pense qu'il sera capable
de comprendre ce geste que j'ai fait
marina hausse et nico va merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté de répondre aux
questions de france 24
depuis moscou et merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cet entretien sur nos antennes
restez-y pour plus d'informations